سياسي ودبلوماسي سعودي كبير هذا الاسبوع
بدا بلقاء ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد
بن سلمان برئيس مجلس القياده اليمني رشد
العليمي حملت تاكيد على دعم الجهود لتوصل
الى حل سياسي شامل في اليمن برعايه امميه
كما تشهد الرياض زياره لرئيس وزراء بولندا
ماتيوس مراوسكي التقى فيها الامير محمد بن
سلمان استعرض خلالها سبلت تعاون الثنائي
بين الرياض وارسو وعلى صعيد النشاط
الدبلوماسي التقى وزير الخارجيه السعودي
بنظيره البريطاني في لندن الازمه
الاوكرانيه تصدرت عناوين هذه الزياره في
ظل انباء عن توجه الامير فيصل بن فرحان
لروسيا ايضا في زياره رسميه وفي الشرق
الاسيوي وتحديدا كوريا الجنوبيه بحث وزير
الدفاع السعودي الامير خالد بن سلمان
التعاون العسكري معصول والتقى خلال
الزياره بالرئيس الكوري يونسوكيول دلالات
واسعه حملتها سياسه السعوديه تجاه
التطورات
اهمها التاكيد السعودي المستمر على
المصالح القوميه وربط استقرار العالمي
بالتنميه وزير الخارجيه السعودي الامير
فيصل بن فرحان اكد ان السعوديه منفتحه على
الحوار مع ايران مضيفا ان الاتفاق النووي
مع ايران ليس مثاليا ويجب ان يعالج مخاوف
دول الجوار واكد وزير الخارجيه السعوديه
انه يوجد اجماع على ان الوضع في سوريا ليس
مقبولا وانه يوجد حوار لعوده سوريا الى
الحضن العربي لكن من المبكر الحديث عن ذلك
وحول الوضع في الاراضي الفلسطينيه اكد
الامير فيصل بن فرحان ان موقف السعوديه
واضح واستقرار وامن الفلسطينيين مشيرا الى
انه توجد احتماليه لمواجهه عنف اكبر اذا
لم يتم حل القضيه الفلسطينيه ايضا اضاف
وزير الخارجي السعودي ان العلاقه مع البيت
الابيض جيده جدا كما ان الصين من اكبر
الحلفاء التجاريين للرياض كما هي مع باقي
العالم
[موسيقى]
وينضم اليه هنا في استديوهات الرياض
الكاتب الصحفي جاسر الجاسر اهلا بك معنا
سيد جاسر يعني دلالات هذا الزخم السياسي
والدبلوماسي من والى الرياض في هذا
التوقيت بالذات في ظل الصراع وتحديات
اقتصاديه وسياسيه كبرى
مساء الخير
الرياض عاصمه النشاط ليس فقط اقليميا في
هذا الجن ما نشهده اليوم هو زخم ايضا
مختلف في تحريك او في تعميق الاستقرار في
العالم يعني اليوم مثلا استقبال الامير
محمد وللعهد لرئيس وزراء البولندي في هذه
الجوله جانب منها مرتبط بالتعاون الثنائي
واعتقد ايضا الجانب اخر مرتبط ايضا في
عمليه اعاده او صياغه السلام في الازمه
الروسيه الاوكرانيه نشهد يعني زياره
الامير فيصل فرحان لاوكرانيا
الاخبار شبه مؤكده او بالطاغيه على
الزياره الموسكو المملكه تتمتع فيها
الموقف لنجد في هذا في الجانب في القدره
او لعلها يمكن الدوله الوحيده التي تتمتع
بعلاقات قويه وثابته ومتينه وشراكه مع
الطرفين المتورطين في الازمه والعالقين في
الازمه وبالتالي هي الصوت مقبول لدى
الجميع ولذلك ممكن تحدث المملكه فرقا
اساسيا وجوهريا في تحقيق هذه المعادله
ولذلك ما يحدث اليوم انا اعتقد بدايات او
مؤشرات لنشاط سيتسع ويتطور في هذا الجانب
هذه حركه نشطه على كافه المستويات لتحقيق
هذا العمل يعني
لقاءات الامير فيصل فرحان مع الوزراء
الخارجيه الدول مجموعه العشرين زياره
بريطانيا كلها تصب في هذا السياق اذا هناك
ملفات المملكه تحرص عليها وتامل عليها
تحقيق الاستقرار والسلام في اليمن
العمل على معالجه الازمات في المنطقه في
العراق وسوريا والعراق وفلسطين ثاني
والمساهم الد في تحقيق الاستقرار العالمي
بما يضمن التنميه والاستقرار ومداد سلاسل
الامداد واليقين الذي تحمله المملكه في
سياسه الخارجيه ان الحرب لا تؤدي الى
المزيد من المشاكل والاعاقه والضرر لجميع
شعوب العالم وبالتالي لابد من البحث عن
خيارات اخرى لتقليص الفارق والوصول الى
نقطه السلام
هي ثبات موقف المملكه العربيه السعوديه من
قضايا كبرى هذا ما يؤكده ربما حديث وزير
الخارجيه السعودي عندما تحدث عن الملف
النووي الايراني عن علاقات المملكه مع
سوريا وعودتها الى الحضن العربي وايضا
العلاقات مع البيت الابيض هذا الثبات في
المواقف كيف سيفتح طرقا ربما لحل لان تكون
السعوديه طرفا في حل ازمه اوكرانيا وغيرها
من الملفات اولا يعني الامير محمد بن
سلمان شخصيه يتمتع بعلاقات قويه ومتينه مع
جميع قاده العالم بشكل يعني يحظى بثقه
هؤلاء القاده وثقه الدول ويتعزز الثقه من
خلال رؤيه المملكه ثبات في السياسه
والرويه التنمويه في المملكه التي حققت
نتائج مذهله ومطوله جدا بالتالي عزت هذا
النمط وهذا الصوره والمرونه والتحرك
الكامل في المملكه مع جميع الاطراف يعني
اذا اخذنا الان في سياق تصريحات الامير
فيصل الامير فيصل تكلم عن نقطتين مثلا
علاقاتنا مع الصين قويه علاقاتنا مع البيت
الابيض قويه نعم نحن مفتحون على جميع
الاطراف لا نستثمر معنا ماذا يحقق هذه
الغايه الاساس اللي هو خدمه مصالح المملكه
اولا بدرجه اساسيه بمعزه العلاقه مع طرف
من الاطراف الخطوه الاخرى التواصل مع جميع
العالم بانفتاح وبدون اشكالات ولان
المملكه لا تنتمي الي محور من المحاور
بشكل واضح ومعين بالتالي هي قمه مقبوله
ومنفتحه على جميع الخيرات النقطه الثالثه
استمراريه التعاون والتعزيز هذه القيمه
بالتالي اليوم احنا في هذا الجانب نعم
البيت الابيض يعني انا اعتقد انه التاكيد
على البيت الابيض السعوديه الامريكيه هي
فيها تحصيل حاصل صحيح يعني نجد انه في بعض
الفتور في الجوانب السياسيه في ملفات
معينه وهذا طبيعي لكن عمق ونوعيه وجذور
الشراكه يعني
منورات الرمال الحمراء وهي استعداد مثلا
على المستويات لكن ايضا حتى المستوى
السياسي يمكن بعض الشباب اللي كانت بدات
تذوب الان في الملف الايراني طبعا موقف
المملكه يعني من قديم وهذا محدد لابد من
الدخول فيه لابد من الوصول الى نتائج
واضحه والتاكيد بانه في حال حدوث خلل في
هذا الملف او هو استطاعت ايران الحصول على
سلاح
نوويات الاخرى ولن تبقى منتظره او مراعاه
يعني مخاوف الدول المجاوره لماذا تكون
شريكه فيها لان اصلا يعني قضيه الملف
النووي هو متصل بالمنطقه اساسا وليس منتصف
الخارج فغياب هذه الشراكه بالتالي تؤدي
ولذلك انا اعتقد المملكه نجحت خلال فتره
من الاتصالات الثنا مع الدول الخمسه اذا
واحد في هذا الجانب في تعديل كثير من
المتصله وبالتالي اليوم نشهد صحه موقف
المملكه من حاله الانهيار والقلق الاوروبي
صدر قبل قليل بيان فرنسي الماني بريطاني
على التشكيك والتاكيد على خلخله في الجانب
اذا جينا في الملف السوري ايضا المملكه
واضحه في الجانب نعم هي اولا اعاده القدره
على تحقيق الاستقرار في المنطقه ما يؤكد
على التنميه والاستقرار المنطقه لابد ان
تعيش الاستقرار وهذه لابد من خلخله او
انتزاع الفتائل التي تؤدي الى هذا التوتر
سوريا ساحه مزعجه ومربكه وساحه الهيمنه
الايرانيه بشكل كبير اذا بالتالي هناك
ترحيب هناك قنوات فتحت هذه الدول التي
قامت علاقات مشهوره وسط سوريا هي تنقل هذه
الرسائل بالامكان هل تستطيع سوريا او
النظام في سوريا ان يقوم بالاجراءات
اللازمه لان يكون فعلا عضوا عربيا حقيقيا
في الجامعه العربيه هذه مؤشرات اذا الباب
مهد وفتح لهذا الجانب فالبقي الدور على
سوريا نفسها يتحرك وان تتحرر من هذه
الارتباطات المزعجه وان تعود ان تكون طرف
وبالتالي ستكون هناك امكانات اخرى ولذلك
الاشاره وصلت الرساله الى الجانب السوري
وبقي التحرك من جانب بما يخص زياره وزير
الدفاع السعودي الامير خالد بن سلمان الى
كوريا الجنوبيه اهميه هذه الزياره من
الناحيه الدفاعيه والتعاون العسكري
تتفق مبدئيا المملكه يعني وضعت استراتيجيه
لتوطين الصناعات العسكريه المملكه ليست
مجرد مشترين ليست مجرد سوق تعمل اليوم على
الاستفاده وتوطين التقنيه والصناعات
والشراكه فيها ولذلك العقود التي تحدث
اليوم والاتفاقات تبحث عن الخيارات التي
تلبي احتياجات المملكه والاطراف القادره
على التعاون في عمليه الصناعه يعني في
بريطانيا حتحقق مساله العمل او اتفاق
النوايا بشان القدرات الجويه المستقبليه
وهذه المرحله المهمه في التصنيع والمشاركه
في التصنيع والتوطين وليس فقط شراء او كذب
هذه النقطه اليوم في كوريا ايضا في الجانب
ونجد انه حتى يعني استقبال الرئيس الكوري
الامير خالد بن سلمان في هذا الجانب يوضح
ان هناك تعاون عميق جدا وهو تعاون يعني لو
ناخذه في مسارات اخرى ايضا كوري في
تعاونتك في علاقه نوعيه مختلفه جدا وهذا
نعتقد ايضا ستكون هناك مرحله اخرى لبناء
تحقيق هذه المنظومه قد نشهد زيارات الامير
خالد لدول اخرى للتوسع في هذا المجال
وبناء شراكات شراكات دفاعيه متينه وقويه
وتحقق المملكه استقرارها شكرا